All right, it's the time of year
where you're either depressed
because you're alone
or depressed
because you're trapped
in a relationship.
Happy Valentine's Day.
To make it extra special,
I gave my Twitter
followers the chance
to proclaim their love on TV
as long as they included
one thing
they wanted to change
about their sweetheart,
in a segment called
Be Mine and Be Better.
I love you Kim, but please stop
gossiping while in the car,
it makes me want to drive
into oncoming traffic.
Love Ron. You don't gossip while
your man is driving a vehicle.
Here's what you do,
you sit there quietly
and about five minutes
before you reach
your destination you say
hey would you like
some road head?
I love you but, I'm also in love
with Swedish Fish
that's my shit,
cha cha cha smiley face.
I love you Rachel, but you got
to stop wearing socks to bed.
Jim. Rachel take off your socks
it's fucking gross.
I love you Amy, but I wish you
knew how to make a decent gravy.
Why is gravy capitalized?
Is that how bad her gravy is?
Amy has no idea,
she's making a subpar gravy.
This guy's not asking
for an excellent gravy,
I want the best gravy.
He wants a decent gravy,
so he can choke down
that dog food you call dinner.
This is the harmonic kiss.
That's how I great my staff
every morning.
Let's them know I still care
without crossing any lines.
Morning guys.
Morning Daniel.
Real mature,
there's not harmonic queefing.
Some people just don't know
how to behave in the workplace.
Look what's on our door,
Princess.
Here's why you never marry
the baby voice girl.
Aw, princess.
Princess Jennifer Ross.
First of all
you're not a princess
Jennifer, princesses vacation
on yachts in the Mediterranean.
Not at amusement parks
in Anaheim.
Look at my flowers, why did
they not put any water in them?
My guess is the poor pussy
whipped bastard that's married
to you wants them to die
just like this relationship.
Holy shmoley, I get a sash.
Look at my fantastically
fantastic princess sash.
Spectacular, spectacular.
Wait I don't never know
how to put a sash on.
I'm not a beauty queen,
did I do it right?
Looks right.
A-ha.
Now give that to your husband
so he can hang himself with it.
Here's my scepter, it's sparkly.
The only way this is worth it is
if that scepter ends up
in her butt later.
Dream. Wow. That's a crown.
Holy moley. It came on
a pillow and everything.
Good lord,
this bitch better have cancer.
Personally I don't treat
my girlfriend like a princess,
I treat her like a queen.
Not just on her birthday,
every day.
Hey I can't find my phone,
will you call it real quick?
This is madness.
I swear on the sword of dragons
that the queen's name
shall never be spoke
in my kingdom again.
Guard.
Fine. I'm getting
Thai food for dinner.
You speak with such disdain,
yet you beg for mercy.
Winter is coming.
If this next pillow could talk
it would be sobbing.
They are gonna so many little
throw pillows.
That's just how you fluff up
a pillow in my house.
I actually had to stop
fucking my couch cushions
because it was always so awkward
at breakfast the next morning.
If that pillow didn't want it,
it shouldn't have worn
that slutty red pillowcase.
Wow you were really aggressive
tonight Cameron,
you're sure you're
not upset about
my parents
staying the weekend?
Here's the best way to keep
your relationships fresh.
Yeah I can't watch this,
I get claustrophobic
if I even hold a girl's hand.
Now psychopaths
can fit five times
as many victims
in their meat locker.
Are you guys smiling?
Just put on matching
white shirts and rolled up jeans
and pose in the sand
like normal lovebirds.
This is what cannibals do
with their leftovers.
You need eat or freeze them
by the end of the month.
I have to preserve my staff
at the end of every season,
but I just pickle them.
All right, see you guys
next season.